tiempo para la información económica en
france 24 para ello contamos con un día
más con nuestro compañero jorge hurtado
jorge bienvenido y comenzamos con la
unión europea que ha aprobado su quinto
paquete de medidas en contra de rusia
rodrigo y es la primera vez que se
incluye una prohibición a las
exportaciones de carbón ruso el impacto
estimado de las sanciones asciende a
cuatro mil millones de euros al año para
rusia aunque puede considerarse pequeño
comparado con los ingresos por gas y
petróleo que representan unos 800
millones al día es para moscú y que por
ahora están fuera de las sanciones
además del embargo al carbón lo que
congelará los activos de varios bancos
rusos y prohibir a las importaciones de
productos rusos por valor de 5.500
millones de euros sobre todo de materias
primas y materiales cítricos estas
sanciones contemplan afectar las
exportaciones rusas en áreas como la
computación cuántica semiconductores
maquinarias sensibles y equipos de
transporte con un daño económico para
rusia que ronda los 10 mil millones de
euros el debate fue bastante incómodo
para países como hungría austria y
alemania que son altamente
del combustible ruso robert ave quien es
ministro de economía de alemania dijo
que su país no se opondrá a la
prohibición de la unión europea hace una
semana este embargo el carbón ruso no
era parte del borrador de sanciones pero
la cantidad de muertes en lucha y otras
ciudades de las afueras de kiev en
ucrania obligaron a la comisión a
redactar de forma urgente sanciones más
contundentes los estados miembros de la
unión europea tienen ahora 120 días para
encontrar proveedores alternativos hasta
ahora el bloque compra a rusia 46 7% del
carbón un 40% del gas natural y un 27%
del petróleo jorge veremos si son las
últimas sanciones en contra de rusia
pasamos ahora a eeuu porque allí la
secretaria del tesoro janet yellen se
pronunció a favor de legislar de regular
las cripto monedas y la primera vez que
la funcionaria habla acerca de la script
o moneda desde que el presidente job
haití pnh firmó una orden ejecutiva
sobre los activos digitales en marzo
pasado yellen centró su discurso en la
importancia de reducir los riesgos de
las monedas digitales para el sistema
financiero así como para mantener la
permanencia del dólar estadounidense y
que el dólar digital un proyecto que aún
está en análisis a su criterio tomaría
años en desarrollarse escuchamos
a medida que los bancos y otras empresas
financieras tradicionales se involucren
más en los mercados de activos digitales
los marcos regulatorios deberán reflejar
adecuadamente los riesgos de estas
nuevas actividades y los nuevos tipos de
intermediarios como los intercambios de
activos digitales y otros intermediarios
nativos digitales deberán estar sujetos
a formas adecuadas de supervisión
venimos ahora a esta américa latina
porque el recién nombrado presidente de
chile gabriel boric ha anunciado un
nuevo paquete de recuperación de 3700
millones bueno este aumento incluye este
paquete incluye un aumento el salario
mínimo también ciertos subsidios como
por ejemplo al transporte y
financiamiento a empresas que fueron
golpeadas por la pandémica todavía no se
recuperan entre los principales
objetivos está la creación de medio
millón de puestos de trabajo y el
aumento del salario mínimo mensual
a los 434 dólares y aumentaría a casi
500 dólares para finales de este año por
ese anuncio que congelaría las tarifas
del transporte público durante el resto
del año y subvencionaría los precios del
combustible escuchemos parte de sus
declaraciones y esto es algo que hemos
estado conversando con la cuota cierto
para aumentar significativamente el
salario mínimo
nuestra meta como ejecutivo es llegar a
los 400 mil pesos este año en honduras
hay nuevas protestas por el alza de los
precios de los combustibles el día de
hoy al menos por 8 horas los
transportistas bloquearon varias de las
principales vías de tegucigalpa pidiendo
un subsidio precisamente por los altos
precios de los combustibles como
consecuencia de la guerra y ucrania los
precios de los combustibles se han
disparado en la región aumentando los
costos de los alimentos y los
combustibles en tegucigalpa los bloqueos
de parte de los transportistas buscan
conseguir este subsidio para compensar
los altos precios de los combustibles el
gobierno dijo que no hay diálogo con
ellos hasta que suspendan este paro en
honduras el galón de gasolina premium
cuesta 4,94 dólares el de regular 4.61 y
él le dice
449 dólares grave el problema en la
región y en todo el mundo jorge acabamos
con los indicadores de las principales
bolsas iniciamos en wall street' que
rebotó tras analizar a fondo las actas
de la reserva federal de eeuu en europa
la bolsa de valores de londres cayó por
el tono bajista en los mercados 2 de
todo el mundo y en américa latina la
bolsa de buenos aires cerró en positivo
tras dos ruedas consecutivas en negativo
buenas noticias para argentinas gracias
jorge por este repaso económico a
nuestros espectadores les invitamos a
que sigan con nosotros en france 24 y
france24 puntocom
[Música]